estos últimos meses no han sido fáciles
para Jacqueline Mister Rigo y sus dos
hijas que han dependido de los comedores
sociales del colegio y de los trabajos
esporádicos para poder subsistir una
realidad compartida por muchos en
Argentina desde que llegué acá
las primeras dos semanas nunca tuve para
darle de comer esas dos semanas mí los
comedores me ayudaron un montón e
incluso con ropa todo aunque la familia
tiene problemas aún más graves tras
recibir una orden de desahucio temen que
los echen de su casa la próxima semana
mira tengo miedo mucho miedo de quedarme
en la calle literalmente de quedarme acá
esperar el desalojo y quedarme en la
calle una situación que puede parecer
insostenible pero por la que muchas
personas atraviesan en el país y que
afecta especialmente a los niños según
un informe del observatorio de la deuda
social Argentina seis de cada 10 menores
viven en condiciones de pobreza en el
país algo que ha aumentado los índices
de trabajo infantil y que todavía podría
empeorar con la alta inflación del país
es muy probable que esto empeoren en un
contexto de inflación porque la gran
mayor la mayor parte digamos de los
ingresos de estos hogares están
destinados a los consumos alimentarios
este último año la inflación ha sido un
problema en todo el mundo pero Argentina
ocupa el segundo lugar en la
clasificación del Banco Mundial solo en
abril el precio de los alimentos aumentó
un 10%, algo que atenta contra el
bienestar de muchas familias y
especialmente de los más pequeños